how's we going with my bird and welcome
to my least favorite game in the entire
world it's cat Mario camera can move
without even moving his legs this go
that's how we do it in Chinatown alright
alright we're doing good we're doing
good
that's okay
I agree why would I be angry I'm in such
a good mood today because Gus new Gossip
Girl episode is that don't you dad ha ha
two can play that game [ __ ]
don't kill me what the what the hell did
I just say one second ago okay cat I
forgot about you why don't you tell me
about the [ __ ] cat
look it know about it huh what the [ __ ]
is titled a bunch of orange s on a
[ __ ] string alright go in what the
hell do I do now wait for the kitty cat
small frame right here Dante
Oh ma'am I even hit the off switch
what does that do okay I did something
well I didn't became longer god damn it
maybe the other one becomes shorter then
that's what I'm hoping on oh oh oh
like a much this is this is part what I
would just stop playing this game and
just reflect on my life and [ __ ] to
reflect them of my dick all right here
we go
oranges oranges jumping goin it's gonna
be fine don't be a goddamn [ __ ] whoo ha
ha [ __ ] you [ __ ] you jump on your bit oh
hey daddy's happened go down
[ __ ] go down mmm Oh what you
gonna do I got a flame truck Thanks why
would they stop [ __ ] oranges we're
going there the flames going never far
but it are going yolo mode oh it's fine
it's fine yeah
oh but the peels look at this skills
look at the skills look at their skills
trampoline object if I don't make this
jump I will cut off one of my left
nipple toppling of justice
I'm a man of my word I should I should
put this away while I'm playing this
game might just kill something these are
[ __ ] difficult because they don't
they they [ __ ] you trap
this part is [ __ ] impossible
seriously I don't like you knew you're
not my friend mushrooms should I take it
coins robot robot what are you doing
don't got it I like your robot don't
robot went to space this is the best
game ever
what note in your van cats should help
each other whoa whoa whoa whoa na ba ba
da ba Joe I don't care this is look like
I give a [ __ ] I might get out of line
here but I'm saying hog the roll out
come here man
come here man brother look I thought he
was a bro I don't think I've ever been
this stuck at it one part of the game
this is just whoa whoa what are we doing
here leap of faith what am I supposed to
do there and we're gonna finish this one
before 100 I can feel it my nipples have
foreseen it seven more seven more bras
is what we're gonna do you are gonna
sing me the most beautiful song you can
ever do and now I'm gonna [ __ ] run
for it you [ __ ] oh I hate you so much
I understand you're not a singer you're
not Celine Dion wait you're are Celine
Dion really you watch my videos Celine
Dion I'm a big fat nice to me man Celine
Dion you [ __ ] you could have told me
about that I [ __ ] hate you
Oh bro Celine what the [ __ ] Celine I'm
serious I'm pissed now 99 this is the
one buzz does like in the movies if
movies has taught me at
that [ __ ] dumped down while I was
talking to me it's like a come oh we're
at hundred now we're gonna make now okay
I got it
all right yes don't get a haircut what
the have it I didn't say don't get a
haircut
oh no Tapley I'm so I'm so sick of this
game right now
[ __ ] you you dick oh I'm job we know
your head what you gonna do what do I do
now
really Tripoli Oh
toots has a plan it may seem crazy but
wait don't win it take me to Narnia oh
this is so I want I don't know if I'm a
hallucinating or seeing this [ __ ] I'm
serious okay
cat Mario what are you doing what are
you doing don't go don't go close to
that Mehcad Mario ching-chong what the
[ __ ] hundred it stopped dying cat Mario
what do you want you have a crown I
don't keep out man my favorite part of
the game thing but stop stop dying for
[ __ ] sake one second I get it get it I
get it
no jumping doesn't help you now
[ __ ]
mmm all right blanket man best game ever
mm-hmm I can't go up there for some
reason where does where did oh dude
skills name
what should
Yolo what what okay pretty good know
what odd in cloud feet bath
how did I do that jump before I wish I
could just teleport back in the future
back in the future yeah that makes sense
I got old Nathan the mushroom don't stop
what do you know about mushrooms
oh [ __ ] I love going cat Mario walks he
won't like this you know I have a new
dog I know my mother please how long
were they will hate to do huh why here
to do oh yeah sorry yeah Mike here
really had a do do do see tonight I just
don't want to play this game anymore I
just don't I don't I don't get it I
don't get I don't I keep dying it's fine
mine but I care
jumping I mean
would you put your put your